[Music]
star talk in the house
what's that what's going on joe i'm neal
how you doing i'm cheese cheese
provolone cheese yes cheese really i
love cheese man cheese this is my smile
guys over there dribbling
gary gary
[Music]
gary
gary okay go on
[Music]
[Applause]
soccer player right here
soccer player
so we we
we are hosts of star talk sports edition
nice and we heard you guys were in the
house yes globetrotters we're in
brooklyn now and brooklyn counts as
being part of the globe yes it does yeah
and so
uh we thought we'd just watch you guys
do stuff do some trick shots it's good
that you came because world trick shot
day is coming up world trick shot what
world trick shot day that's a thing it's
a thing world trick shot day you get one
guess who invented it right
i'm gonna try okay
okay
so we're gonna we're gonna give science
commentary right on your trick shot
training that's what we're gonna do okay
yeah i'm excited i'm gonna side side
break it down
that's all right all right okay
all right
[Music]
walk spinning a um
on an index finger
later
trademark
tag mark yes yes
let's see what you got
nice
okay so the spin
it gives you
puts it in the spin is just like the
spin is real critical because
i think a lot of great players know how
to use that backboard yeah yeah so you
can get a layup like this
but if i want to be cool and flashy i
can give you a spin and let the spin do
all the work
i'm just getting it up uh-huh yeah i can
do that
[Laughter]
just like a football the spin stabilizes
the ball on the finger except here it's
different so there's some physics in
here can i tell you something all right
let's go okay chuck pay attention come
on
everybody
all right so here's the thing here's the
thing
so
you according to newton's laws of motion
yes sir
you cannot just set something into
motion
unless something gets sent backwards
because of it
okay so every action is an equal and
opposite reaction okay so watch what
happens if i spin the ball
right
whoa
it's it started moving that way yes sir
did anything go that way in response
no no so what happened i'll tell you
what happened the friction with the
court
sent earth backwards
to counteract the ball going forwards
with the same momentum
but the earth is huge
so this has a small mass and it has
high velocity forward this has a huge
mass and very low velocity forward no
one even notices it wow
you know yeah so the earth is is
feeling everybody's acceleration on the
cars when you're running how is it i can
start at zero speed and just go forward
i'm pushing backwards against the earth
and the earth is like feeling this
except everybody's doing it in every
direction and it just all cancels out
right
that's kidding me
yeah there it is it works for me
you just made me feel sorry for the
earth
and mother nature
[Music]
taking a cue from space probes
we're going to do a multi-planet gravity
assist to the basket
and all three of us are the planets
let's go let's do this
oh yeah
oh yeah yeah
how you doing
that's how you work
so in physics we know that rotating
objects are stabilized
as they move through space so bullets
guns have rifling which spins a bullet
stabilizing its path uh spinning planets
are more stable than non-spinning
planets so
it's just one of those things so when
you guys spin the ball i'm saying you
got some good physics there but that
doesn't mean it's easy right doesn't
mean it's easy so
you're gonna teach me how to do this
ready i used to be able to do that i
don't know what happened that's why you
gotta do it in five seconds okay let's
do that let's do that
the logo
okay
oh yeah
this has been star talk sports edition
the harlem globetrotters
neil degrasse tyson here as always keep
looking up
[Applause]
[Music]
you